on se le ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov vient de
terminer son discours à l'occasion de la
conférence de moscou sur la sécurité
internationale et on revient sur cette
prise de parole avec pierre laurin
journaliste et auteur spécialiste de
l'urss du monde post soviétique et de la
russie pierre laurin merci d'avoir suivi
avec nous cette prise de parole de
sergueï lavrov alors la russie est
ouverte au dialogue à condition du
respect mutuel
c'est par ces mots que sergueï lavrov a
conclu son discours est ce que ça résume
un petit peu cette prise de parole
finalement oui ça résume la prise de
parole mais également l'attitude de la
russie depuis un certain temps c'est ce
que nous disions avant le l'intervention
du ministre la france c'est que la
russie se trouve dans une position de
proposition de rencontre noah rencontres
internationales de discussions etc
et c'est plutôt depuis en particulier
depuis l'affairé craignait en 2014 mais
également avant parce que les inimitiés
ne date pas exclusivement de l'affairé
crânienne les occidentaux se trouvent
dans une position de refus de refus
parce qu'on ne peut pas en même temps
sanctionner un pays lui mettre des
bâtons dans les roues sur tous les
niveaux stratégiques et en même temps
accepter un dialogue d'égal à égal c'est
ça le problème c'est que à partir du
moment où on considère qu'un pays se
trouve en infériorité idéologique pour
le coup à l'époque soviétique c'était
les soviétiques qui étaient les
idéologues et les occidentaux les
pragmatiques aujourd'hui ce sont les
occidentaux les idéologues et les russes
qui sont les pragmatiques et on ne peut
pas établir un dialogue à partir du
moment où on considère l'autre comme en
état d'infériorité
donc c'est exactement ce que vient de
dire ce que vient de conclure seule
grille lavrov
effectivement la diplomatie offensive
américaine a été abordé à au début du
cours du sergueï lavrov tout comme
l'attitude de l'otan pour autant il a
rappelé qu'il y avait des espaces de
dialogue notamment sur le nucléaire on
pense au traité new start
tout cela dans le sillage de la
rencontre entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine la semaine dernière il y a tout
de même des terrains d'entente c'est ce
qu'il a exprimé également
oui mais il ya des terrains d'entente in
extremis parce que souvenons nous que
les américains refusé de proroger le
traité new star ait refusé d'engager des
négociations sur ce qui allait succéder
au traité news parle c'est à dire un
autre traité dans la logique de ce qui
existe depuis les années 70 la détente
c'est à dire que là il y avait une
interruption brutale d'un mouvement qui
durait depuis des décennies et ce n'est
qu'en février de cette année juste après
l'inauguration de du président byden le
20 janvier que les états unis ont
accepté de proroger new star pour cinq
ans c'est à dire le temps de se donner
une possibilité de négocier quelque
chose d'envergure et c'est ça le premier
geste réel fait par les états unis en
direction de la russie qui a été
concrétisée par la rencontre entre joba
eden et vladimir poutine de 16 juin mais
à partir du moment où les américains
accepté réellement de rentrer dans le
jeu de la négociation il était évident
que cette rencontre allait avoir lieu
il ne pouvait pas en être autrement
sinon les a même cas ce serait resté
serait resté pas rond sur la position de
donald trump et il n'aurait pas accepté
de deux projets new stap qui entraient
qui était devenu qui devenait caduque
dans les semaines qui suivaient cette
décision américaine de proroger pour
cinq ans alors autres dossiers abordés
c'est la question de la sécurité
informatique a
c'est 9,1 finalement dans les relations
entre les deux pays puisqu'elle arrive
en même temps que la révolution
numérique donc une volonté de part et
d'autre de coopérer sur cette question
de cyberattaques
là encore c'est sait quelque chose c'est
une perspective finalement positive
oui c'est une perspective positive à
condition qu' elle soit suivi d'effet 1
nous avons là une décision de
collaboration qui vient d'être prise
des experts se réunissent ils vont
élaborer des solutions à moyen ou à long
terme on n'en sait rien pour le moment
mais il suffit que pour une raison ou
pour une autre les états unis décident
que ce n'est pas profitable pour eux
pour que cette initiative s'interrompent
donc être restons prudents mais il y a
un véritable pas en avant qui a été fait
parce que s'il ya une collaboration sur
la cyber sécurité
cela signifie que les accusations des
âmes des autres sur les attaques de
hackers supposé située en russie ou
commandités par des intérêts russes tu
serait examinée réellement et non pas on
ne resterait pas dans le flou ah oui
mais les adresses ip était en russie
alors que bon ça ne signifie strictement
rien mais en tout cas je pense que si
réellement il ya une volonté réelle
d'aller de l'avant sur des négociations
en ce sens entre les deux pays
ce genre d'accusation serait mise à plat
et peut-être que on assainir et la
situation des accusations gratuites
très souvent par foire l on n'en sait
rien at a donné que nous n'avons qu'une
preuve rêve de ce qui se passe on ne
peut croire que les partis sont les pros
américains et ont dit à ces de
russes
soit on est plutôt neutres ou du côté de
la rue
si l on dit mais non ce sont des
accusations purement gratuite est bon de
toute façon en matière de cybersécurité
personne n'est blanc à ce que c'est
c'est un système qui est vital pour tout
pays de savoir ce que fait l'adversaire
et éventuellement de pouvoir le contrer
donc là il n'y a pas d'accusation réel a
porté sur une partie alors que l'autre
serait totalement blanche il y a eu
aussi bien évidemment le dossier
ukrainien qui a été abordé par sergueï
lavrov est finalement bien les alliés
des américains en europe montrent
également du doigt
oui bien sûr mais sur le dossier
ukrainien il ya une évolution vraiment
intéressante est en train de se produire
jusqu'à il ya très peu de temps tous les
pays occidentaux étaient derrière
l'ukraine
certains militer ouvertement pour son
entrée dans l'otan mais en tout cas tout
le monde désigne et les séparatistes ou
du moins les autonomistes du dun base
comme les fauteurs de troubles soutenu
par la russie et donc c'était la russie
qui était coupable de tout là on assiste
à une certaine modulation une modération
dans l'est dans les attaques en
particulier ce qui est très important
c'est que concernant l'entrée de
l'ukraine dans l'otan
le président ben ali donne un très
clairement dit que c'était effectivement
une perspective mais qu'elle était liée
à la lutte contre la corruption
à l'intérieur de l'ukraine or l'ukraine
est un système le système économique et
politique ukrainien et un système qui
est profondément imbriquées avec la
corruption avec les oligarques russes
ukrainiens qui mène la barque que ce
sont eux qui décident et même un
président qui était investi du rôle de
créer la paix les conditions de la paix
par 73% du peuple ukrainien
se trouve désarmés face aux oligarques
qui lui feront des chantages divers et
il est obligé de s'aligner sur des
positions qui n'était pas celle qu'il
avait au départ pour conclure pierre
laura les 27 ans me dans le même temps
sont eux réunis à bruxelles et le couple
franco-allemand a dit souhaiter
aujourd'hui plus de dialogue avec la
russie
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
évolution dans les relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie
à partir du moment où il y à une
évolution entre les états unis et la
russie
il ya forcément une évolution entre
l'union européenne la russie et l'union
européenne ne peut pas se permettre de
rester en dehors d'un mouvement
on ne sait pas encore quelle importance
aura ce mouvement mais il risque d'être
intéressant et donc je pense que l'union
européenne est dans son rôle de de
servir comment dirais-je de troisième
pilier d'une éventuelle évolution vers
une meilleure entente entre les nations
dont en plus qu' il y à une partie des
peuples européens qui font partie de
l'union européenne qui n'ont pas une
position anti russe du tout au contraire
ils aspirent à une amélioration des
relations et qu' il ya des candidats
comme la serbie qui peuvent intégrer
éventuellement l'union européenne qui ne
l'intégreront pas tant qu' il y aura un
différend entre l'union européenne la
russie ça également donc tout ça ça doit
être prise en compte
jobin et dan a donné le feu vert à
genève et maintenant c'est aux européens
de faire un geste et effectivement le
geste d'une rencontre avec poutine pour
mettre les choses à plat sera
vraisemblablement accepter par le
président russe
merci beaucoup pierre laurent de d'avoit
de nous avoir aidés à analyser à la
prise de parole de sergueï lavrov le
ministre des affaires étrangères il
s'exprimait lors de la conférence de
moscou sur la sécurité internationale
conférence qui a débuté hier
et qui se termine ce soir merci pierre
laurent